parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi PS quand
je parle de bout de chemin je veux dire
des parts de chez moi arrivé au boulot
puis de retour maison si possible tous
les jours merci à toi le covoiturage
c'est convivial économiques et
écologique avec le covoiturage 50 ans en
Yvelines vous propose une nouvelle façon
de vous déplacer les inscriptions et les
infos sur www.covoiturage.aglo-sqy.fr
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro d'équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable un numéro consacré
à l'éco-construction pour tout savoir
sur les nouvelles façons de concevoir
l'habitat de demain mais aussi sur les
nouveaux matériaux utilisés et les
nouvelles filières professionnelles pour
répondre à toutes ces questions nous
nous trouvons au sein de l'École
nationale supérieure d'architecture en
votre compagnie Nadia oyeh bonjour et
merci de nous recevoir alors qu'est-ce
que les co-constructions
on pourrait définir l'éco-construction
comme une construction écologique écho
étant la contraction de d'écologie alors
construction écologique c'est une
construction qui est respectueuse de
l'environnement alors en premier lieu
c'est une construction qui lorsqu'elle
est en fonctionnement ne consomme le
moins possible d'énergie alors pour
consommer moins d'énergie
comme ça maintenant tout le monde le
sait on isole on met un manteau autour
de la maison on fait dans mais on change
les fenêtres on met des fenêtres
isolantes mais on peut aussi profiter de
ce qu'on appelle dans notre terme
jergoneux des apports solaires
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on a tout autour
de notre environnement des ressources et
en particulier le soleil qui peut être
utilement
mis à profit pour nous chauffer mais
même chauffer directement au travers des
fenêtres nous chauffer aussi par des
capteurs thermiques vous savez qui vont
chauffer l'eau et qui vont donner de
l'eau sanitaire chaude ou bien mettre du
chauffage central c'est ce qu'on appelle
un habitat bioclimatique c'est ce qu'on
appelle exactement un habitat
bioclimatique
et
donc là c'est donc une construction qui
va consommer le moins possible d'énergie
maintenant c'est aussi une construction
qui consomme à peu énergie lors de sa
construction et c'est ça qui est aussi
assez nouveau et ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les matériaux modernes le
ciment le béton le verre aussi consomme
beaucoup d'énergie quand on les fabrique
et traditionnellement on avait passé
matériaux là donc quand on va puiser
dans les matériaux traditionnels en fait
on a à disposition des matériaux qui
consomment très peu d'énergie pour pour
être fabriqué et qui ont même la faveur
de nous fournir de l'oxygène si ce sont
des matériaux qui poussent donc le bois
et aussi pour les isolants on a on fait
appel maintenant au chanvre au lin tout
des plantes qui étaient
traditionnellement utilisées elles ont
des propriétés tout à fait étonnantes et
on les utilise dans la fabrication de
matériaux de construction alors des
isolants je les dis mais aussi on peut
utiliser les fibres de chanvre pour
renforcer du béton
on fait des associations comme ça de
matériaux et alors l'éco-construction ce
n'est pas uniquement l'habitat
individuel c'est aussi des des quartiers
co-construits qui peuvent être pensés
demain en fait quand on réfléchit sur
sur ces quartiers durables on va
installer des infrastructures qui vont
être un petit peu différentes de ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui très très orienté
sur l'automobile donc des circulations
douces avec plus de vélo plus
confortables plus de chemin piétons plus
confortables aussi
essayez aussi de rapprocher mais ça
c'est difficile mais rapprocher
l'habitat des lieux de travail pour
éviter les longs les longs transports
très bien merci pour toutes ces
précisions qui sont les architectes de
demain quels sont les nouvelles filières
professionnelles et les nouvelles
réalisations réponse en images
j'avais déjà une envie à la sortie du
BTS donc bac + 2 de justement promouvoir
ce cette envie de construire tout en
respectant l'environnement et limiter
nos impacts la profession évolue vers
vers le durable et donc tout n'a pas
encore été mise en place pour développer
ce que va être la construction demain
l'éco-construction ne fait que commencer
ce matin Laetitia Vincent et leurs
camarades travaillent à l'élaboration
d'un centre-ville à Élancourt
réintroduire des circulations douces et
des pôles d'intérêt et laisser plus
d'espace à l'humain créer il y a 4 ans à
lansaab le master spécialisé à
l'éco-construction et à l'aménagement
des quartiers durables s'effectuent en
apprentissage et en partenariat avec
l'Université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines si ce matin le
projet reste fictif celui de la
résidence universitaire de Guyancourt et
bien réel le bâtiment départ était prévu
avec une performance passive
c'est-à-dire qu'on se met vraiment très
peu d'énergie et nous avons placé au
stade supérieur pour le pour le
développer en bâtiment positif à énergie
positive et tous usages pour cela les
multiples partenaires du projet ont
travaillé sur l'enveloppe thermique du
bâtiment mais pas seulement le béton
utilisé possède une faible empreinte
environnementale les façades seront
isolées d'un bardage en bois et la
toiture recouverte de panneaux
photovoltaïques
fondatéral va aussi sensibiliser les
utilisateurs aux économies d'énergie un
système de bonus malus sera instauré sur
les quittances de loyer des étudiants
les comportements vertueux seront
récompensés par une diminution du prix
du loyer à terme 150 chambres étudiantes
seront disponibles la résidence
universitaire sera opérationnelle pour
la rentrée 2015
est-ce que
l'habitat éco-construit ce n'est pas
pour demain c'est tout de suite et avec
vous Xavier Molinas bonjour nous allons
étudier des cas bien concrets puisque
depuis trois ans votre entreprise
l'ardoise aux zinc s'est tourné vers ces
nouveaux matériaux et co-construit
pourquoi ce choix pourquoi ce virage
pour des qualités de pose des qualités
de l'isolant de meilleure qualité pour
avoir quelque chose de concret pour
avoir une qualité de pose plus
confortable pour nos poseurs et pour
nous-mêmes c'est à dire que ça
n'entraîne pas contrairement à la laine
de verre à la laine de roche des
irritations par rapport au laine de
verre par rapport au laine minérale on a
beaucoup moins de problèmes
respiratoires quand on la pose surtout
quand on la dépose ensuite pour les
qualités qui sont les qualités normales
pour une laine végétale c'est-à-dire les
traversées de chaleur en été comme les
traces versées de température en hiver
sont de bien meilleure qualité les
effets contre les nuisibles puisque les
nuisibles s'installent pas dans les
mêmes végétal ne sont beaucoup plus
intéressantes
on utilise des laines de chanvre et un
panneau de bois pour une finition pour
avoir une finition phonique et isolation
au vent et isolation à la pluie
meilleure condition de travail aussi
pour les ouvriers un répulsif pour les
rongeurs et aussi une meilleure
résistance à l'humidité et donc une
meilleure résistance dans le temps et
surtout une pour le confort intérieur
comme je vous disais une meilleure
résistance à la chaleur en été donc les
traversées de chaleur sont moins longues
donc la maison à l'intérieur est
beaucoup plus confortable en été en plus
des résistances thermiques qui sont
habituelles à une isolant ce que
minérale non pas par exemple et donc au
niveau rapport qualité prix parce que
c'est un peu plus onéreux que les laines
à densité égale on est quasiment même
pris on est légèrement plus cher en
laine de chambre on fait des gros
efforts sur les prix pour justement pas
exploser le budget
isolant mais on est quand même à qualité
égale quasiment la même chose pour
autant et on va le voir dans le sujet
qui va suivre
récupère très très vite l'investissement
initial dans les données techniques des
centres de CTSB d'autres centres du
bâtiment les données sont à 37% de perte
de chaleur par la toiture les retours
clients sont plutôt autour des 50% donc
on peut baser entre 30 à peu près à 40 %
de perdre d'énergie ce qui permet de
diviser presque la facture de la facture
de consommation à mieux par deux est-ce
que éventuellement la paille dont on
parle peut aussi faire partie de ces
nouveaux isolants la taille peut faire
partie de ces nouveaux isolants ils sont
beaucoup moins écologiques puisqu'il
faut utiliser des produits pour les uns
pour les traiter contre les rongeurs
donc c'est pour ça et on a moins de
facilité pour les travaux en toiture
avec la paille merci pour tous ces
renseignements nous allons à présent
voir deux cas bien concrets de clients
qui ont pu profiter de ces matériaux
éco-construits témoignages
c'est une grande maison à chauffer et
que je sais que j'ai beaucoup de
déperdition par le toit en fuel ça fait
quand même chers parents face à ces
importantes des perditions d'énergie
joël a décidé d'entamer des travaux son
voisin Richard a procédé à la même
isolation de sa toiture deux ans plus
tôt chez lui les résultats sont déjà là
immédiatement on a consommé deux fois
moins de
mazout que ce qu'on faisait donc on
était ici à peu près à 4000 4500 litres
par an et là on est descendu sous les
2000 litres une facture réduite de
moitié mais pas n'importe comment
Richard soucieux d'une isolation durable
et des répercussions sur la santé s'est
tourné vers des matériaux biologiques
laine de chanvre fibre de bois ouate de
cellulose ou encore liège expansé ces
matériaux respectent l'environnement dès
leur conception ils sont également sains
pour les poseurs et les utilisateurs
troisième aspect leur performance nous
avons des produits qui sont très perform
qui ont des caractéristiques c'est vrai
différents des isolants notamment à base
de l'aide minérale parce que ce sont ici
du végé du monde végétal donc ils ont
une capacité à gérer la vapeur d'eau
dans l'isolant et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très important hiver comme été
dernier point positif la durabilité
Hélène végétale contrairement aux laines
minéral comme la laine de roche ont une
durée de vie garantie de 50 ans de quoi
amortir le prix des travaux car si le
coût est plus élevé de 20 à 30% que les
isolants classiques les économies
engendrées immédiatement et la
durabilité des matériaux convainc de
plus en plus de clients qui imposent ces
matériaux aux entrepreneurs
ainsi s'achève ce nouveau numéro
d'équilibre qui vous donnera peut-être
des idées de rénovation avant de nous
quitter quelques dates éco-construites à
noter dans vos agendas l'Agence Locale
de l'énergie du climat vous donne
rendez-vous à la Maison de
l'Environnement le 23 mars pour une
randonnée construire passif c'est
positif l'occasion de découvrir des cas
concrets de rénovation en bois ou
végétalisées et puis on reste à la
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie du climat
le 6 avril pour un atelier ma maison
éco-construite pour apprendre à
concevoir sa maison de manière
écologique et économique dès 8 ans nous
on se retrouve le 19 avril pour un
nouveau numéro d'équilibre Ciao